el comité que Investiga lo que ocurrió
en La Toma del Capitolio el 6 de enero
del 2021 remitió al expresidente Donald
Trump al departamento de Justicia por
cuatro delitos primero por obstruir un
procedimiento oficial segundo por
conspirar para defraudar a los Estados
Unidos tercero por conspiración para
hacer una declaración falsa y cuarto por
incitar asistir o ayudar o consolar una
insurrección Jimmy congresista por
Maryland hizo el anuncio oficial al
concluir una investigación que duró 18
meses hay que Resaltar que esta acción
no tiene peso legal para Donald Trump
sin embargo es la primera vez en la
historia que el congreso hace esta
recomendación al departamento de
Justicia que ya adelanta una
investigación independiente por su
cuenta y que podría terminar en más
acusaciones contra el expresidente Trump
el comité también está remitiendo a
cuatro congresistas al comité de ética
por ignorar las recomendaciones del
panel que Investiga lo ocurrido El Seis
de enero Estos son el líder de La
minoría republicana Kevin mccarthy y
posiblemente el próximo presidente del
Congreso y los representantes Jim Jordan
de Ohio scorpio Pensilvania y Andy bigs
de